[Music]
there's never been a black cop in this
city
we think you might be the man to open
things up around here
[Music]
hello this is ron stallworth calling who
am i speaking with this is david duke
grand wizard of the ku klux klan that
david duke
god last time i checked what can i do
for well
since you asked i hate blacks i hate
jews
mexicans and irish italians and chinese
but my mouth to god's ears i really hate
those black rats and anyone else really
that doesn't have pure white aryan blood
running through their veins
i'm happy to be talking to a true white
american god bless white america
the kkk is planning an attack how do you
propose to make this investigation
we'll establish contact over the phone
we'll need a white officer
to play me when they meet face to face
you feel the white race wrong
oh hell yeah so there becomes a combined
ron staller
can you do that with the right white man
we can do anything
when's the last time they let a rookie
lead an investigation oh that's right
never okay become his friend let's get
invited back so what kind of stuff you
guys do
cross burnings marches this is fixing to
be a big year for us
you asked too many questions we
undercover or something
we must unite and organize to fight
racism
are you down for the liberation of black
people power to the people all power to
all the people oh power
to all the people that's right for you
it's a crusade for me it's a job you're
jewish that hatred doesn't that piss you
off you're taking this july detector
test
why are you acting like you ain't got
skin in the game
i'm telling you a war wars are common
[Music]
knights of the ku klux klan that's us
stalwart brothers
[Music]
we're on a roll baby
america first america america
if i would have known this was a plan i
would have taken this mother
[Music]
you